ja wir sind im fünften kriegs monat in
der ukraine und auch heute wollen wir
uns ansehen wie denn der krieg sich
entwickelt vor allem aktuell im osten
des landes und welche waffensysteme
welche strategien die beiden seiten
einsetzen wir sehen uns also noch mal
die lage hier an die ist im osten des
landes für die ukrainische armee
ziemlich verzweifelt die hat nach
wochenlangen kämpfen die gesamte region
lohans verloren und jetzt wird wieder
internets gekämpft und netzte diese
große region kann man vielleicht noch
mal ein zeichnen hier sehr große region
die sich etwa hier bewegt hier gab es
anfang des krieges im mario pohl im
süden sehr starke kämpfe wir uns alle
dort hat die russische armee nach etwa
drei monaten gewonnen und jetzt
konzentrieren sich die kämpfe auf kramer
tors konstanz die best letzten beiden
großstädte die hier gehalten werden die
ukrainische armee setzt bei ihrer
verteidigung dieser nicht nur dieser
provinz sondern auch natürlich des
südens des landes immer mehr auch
westliche waffen und wir können uns mal
ansehen wie professionell sie
mittlerweile geworden ist in den waffen
von denen noch einige westliche ja
staatschef noch vor monaten gesagt haben
nein die sind viel zu kompliziert für
die die sowjetisch waffen haben die
können wir uns nicht umgehen wir sehen
uns mal an was sie mit der französischen
césar machen die sie auch erst seit etwa
einem monat betreiben und ich lasse das
video einfach wir durchlaufen wir sehen
uns mal an diese diese artillerie
geschütze auf einem lkw ist halb
automatisch das heißt da muss die ganze
zeit gearbeitet werden und diese
ukrainischen soldaten hier sind absolute
profis geworden in nur wenigen wochen in
der handhabung das war der erste schuss
den wir da gesehen haben und jetzt wird
hier weiter vorbereitet da wird die
treibladung sozusagen hier eingeführt
von der seite und der zweite schuss ist
dann nach wenigen sekunden schon da wir
haben 30 sekunden bisher in diesem video
und wir sehen uns noch das video bis zu
ändern das sind 45 sekunden und es sind
drei schüsse abgegeben werden das ist
ein absoluter rekord und da das ist
absolut auf dem niveau auch von
westlichen armeen und der französischen
armee die dieses gerät bisher bedient
haben wir sehen also hier 30 sekunden 45
sekunden drei schüsse das ist extrem
wichtig weil die ukraine danach schnell
wieder weg müssen es geht also wirklich
darum zielgerichtet von einer position
aus schnell zu schießen und danach
wieder wegzufahren denn dann kommt das
gegen artillerie feuer der russen die
danach auf diese position nicht schießen
was beschießen die ukraine damit ja das
sind immer mehr waffenlager hinter der
front weit hinter der front wir haben
laut britischen geheimdienst angaben elf
waffenlager allein in den letzten zwei
wochen der letzten woche zerstört wurden
eins davon hier in der stadt donetzk und
das sind hier einfach passanten die
vorbeikommen die sehen das große feuer
dort und sie sehen dann vor sich auf der
straße was dann dort liegt was in diesem
waffenlager drin war und dass eben nicht
nur die großen raketen die großen bomben
sondern wie sehen sie jetzt hier das
sind ganz einfache panzerfaust munition
also ganz einfach kann das ist kurz mal
angucken das ist eine von sogenannten
erp b7 eine alte sowjetische panzerfaust
aber eben auch die ist wichtig auch die
steht den russen jetzt nicht mehr zur
verfügung um eben an der front
eingesetzt zu werden ja und wir sehen
die ist also mehrere hundert meter aus
diesen explodierenden waffenlager hier
herausgeflogen auf der straße gelandet
und die passanten in ihr in der
besetzten stadt meßkirch und sich das
einfach mal an was denn da alles
sozusagen aus diesen aus diesem jahr
werke rausgeflogen ist wir wollen es
auch ansehen was wir bisher ganz selten
bloß getan haben die ukrainische flug ab
während die uhren ukrainische flugabwehr
ist auch im fünften kriegs monat
weiterhin aktiv sie ist im land jede
nacht bei der arbeit russischen marsch
flugkörper abzuschießen russische
ballistische raketen abzuschießen und
nach eigenen angaben relativ
realistischen angaben haben sie bisher
etwa 100 dieser marschflugkörper und
raketen aus russland und aus dem
schwarzen meer abgeschossen das sind nur
drei prozent der über 3000 raketen die
bislang abgefeuert wurden aber wir
wissen wir sehen es hier das ist die
explosion
drei prozent aber 100 raketen hin oder
her wenn wir wissen dass allein eine
davon beispielsweise in einem supermarkt
20 menschen getötet hat oder in einer
schule zehn menschen getötet hat dann
sind das jede nacht die lebensretter die
ukrainischen die hier weiterhin an der
ja sozusagen das land verteidigen und
auch monate nach kriegsbeginn eben dafür
sorgen dass die raketen zumindest zu
einem teil nicht durchkommt und dass die
russische luftwaffe das ist auch ganz
interessant im westen und im zentrum des
landes überhaupt nicht mehr aktives die
trauen sich dann nicht mehr über seit
monaten trauen sie sich nicht
überschießend nur noch mit raketen und
flugkörpern weil eben auch etwa 100
russische flugzeuge von der ukrainischen
luftabwehr abgeschossen wurde wurden und
wir sprechen hier nicht von diesen
schulter gestützten geschützten sondern
wir sprechen tatsächlich von großen
geschützen zuallerletzt wollen wir uns
ansehen auch neue aufnahmen die gestern
veröffentlicht wurden hier wieder
ukrainische glücklicher soldaten war
unglücklich daten sie sitzen auf einem
113 aus dänemark auch den markt liefert
jetzt gepanzerte mannschaftstransporter
vom typ m 113 die hier an die ukraine
gegeben werden ja nicht nur jene mag
sondern eben zahlreiche westliche länder
wir sehen hier also das kann man so pro
drinsitzen ich denke bei dem guten
wetter und bei der temperatur sitzen die
soldaten dann hier oben drauf wir haben
ja auch hier ein friedliches gebiet aber
eben die panzerung die das liefert um
soldaten von a nach b zu bewegen die ist
extrem wichtig und viele europäische
länder liefern mittlerweile westlich ist
hier amerikanisch das gerät deutschland
bislang noch nicht und trotzdem hofft
man eben darauf oder die ukraine hoffen
darauf dass auch deutschland endlich
hier etwas liefert beispielsweise den
transportpanzer fuchs von dem 200 zur
verfügung ständen und eben nur noch nach
entscheidungen von olaf scholz dann auch
geliefert werden könnten